jérôme lambert maxence briquet bonjour
bonjour bonjour merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france pour échanger
débattre sur l'actualité pour commencer
votre réaction emmanuel macron fait
durer le suspense sur sa candidature il
dit refuser de se déclarer candidat tant
que les crises sanitaires et
géopolitiques ne sont pas derrière nous
vous en pensez quoi jérôme lambert
c'est une brève nouvelle il sera jamais
candidat à la
non mais bon cela dit je suis membre du
apparenté au groupe socialiste mais je
suis adhérent du mouvement des citoyens
un du parti socialiste mais ce n'est
qu'un détail
oui je dis se déclarent qu'ils se
déclarent plus rapidement
mais il fera ce qu'il veut mais enfin
tout le monde personne n'est dupe
simplement aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il
échappe à
la possibilité de mettre tous et ses
dépenses de campagne dans ses frais de
campagne monsieur le vice vécu des
détails que voilà mais ça paraît un peu
grotesque que le fait de dire je ne
serai candidat que quand il sera jamais
candidat la présente crise ça sera
terminé les élections sont déjà passés
sur ce maxi les quais
je partage complètement
j'ajouterai que non seulement il ne sera
jamais candidat mais qu'en plus il
contribue à ne pas l'être étant donné
que sa gestion des crises notamment
sanitaires et le jeu politique sont
extrêmement mauvaises et que c'est
notamment pour ça qu'aujourd'hui il va
devoir repousser son entrée en campagne
tôt qu'elle ne sont pas réglés comme
disait monsieur lambert en effet ça lui
évite de devoir pour l'instant fin
ventricules ses dépenses dans les
comptes de campagne 70 avec l'argent des
français emmanuel macron est un habitué
il l'avait déjà fait longuement enfin
dès 2021 en allant à marseille en
proposant des plans à plusieurs
milliards pour les banlieues pour
construire un tram etc donc les mesures
clientélistes on d'un côté des présentes
sur toute la partie clientéliste de son
approche électorale est aujourd'hui fait
des déplacements à droite à gauche il
nous paraît de schengen nous parler de
la réforme de l'union européenne tout un
tas de sujets qui ne sont pas
prioritaires on va dire dans l'esprit
des français est aujourd'hui macro n'a
malheureusement rien d'autre à dire que
ça sa gestion de la crise sanitaire
parce que ne souhaite que monopolisé
sujet lab qui n'a rien d'autre à leur
raconter que son bilan est absolument
désastreux dans tous les autres domaines
de la crise sanitaire et conclu
l'entente macron tient organisé hier
soir une rencontre autour des chrétiens
d'orient l'occasion pour le chef de
l'état de lancer un message à
l'électorat catholique regarder
rappelait soutenir les chrétiens
d'orient c'était agir pour un orient
pluriel pour la possibilité même de la
paix et de la fraternité
c'est comprendre
qu'un si on ne fait pas simplement de
protéger des communautés on leur donne
la possibilité de continuer d'agir dans
l'intérêt de tous et comme une nécessité
pour tous maxence briquet il marche sur
les plates-bandes de valérie pécresse et
et d'eric zemmour le chef de l'état
je pense que chef de l'état ne marche
pas dedans de personnes déjà parce que
les gens pour qu'ils veulent c'est la
première des choses mais un deuxième
essai à mon avis plus important c'est
que emmanuel macron fait encore la
girouette et donne du grain à moudre à
droite à gauche et c'est alors qu'on
sait très bien enfin je veux dire qu'il
n'a jamais été un très grand défenseur
des catholiques en france j'en veux pour
preuve le fait que ne se rendait pas
compte que les catholiques avec les
juifs sont le dire la communauté mais
saab si mentalement terme sont les
pratiquants les croyants les plus
menacées de france vous avez eu en 2019
plus de 1000 actes antichrétiens en
france plus de 500 actes antijuifs et
vous avez vu sans actes anti musulmans
qui sont tous évidemment condamnable
c'est évident nous tous les actes anti
religieux sont une sont une abomination
mais ça pourrait être intéressant que le
chef de l'état prenne conscience du
risque qu'ils courent la chrétienté dans
notre pays qui est un pays
historiquement chrétiens aux racines
chrétiennes et l'eczéma on lui souhaite
défendre ses racines chrétiennes de la
france et a exercé le candidat de la
france des clochers des villages et
aujourd'hui même à crans et candidat des
villes mondialise et les banlieues donc
on n'est pas du tout sur le même terrain
politique jérôme lambert vous partagez
une constament maxence de maxence
briquet
déjà je voudrais dire que le président
de la république quand il indique que
je suis soutenir les chrétiens d'orient
c'est c'est garantir la paix au
moyen-orient - que je sache le problème
les problèmes du moyen-orient sont
jamais des problèmes entre les chrétiens
et des musulmans jamais même dans le
conflit arménie azerbaïdjan ce n'est pas
un conflit religieux ça n'a rien à voir
c'est un confit territoire ancestral
donc ne mélangeons pas tout maintenant
et à saran maxime est ce que max un
briquet à la main quand maxime briquet
évident que les racines chrétiennes de
la france oui l'histoire en france mais
la france aujourd'hui ce qui la
caractérise dans le monde et ce qui fait
sa une forme de spécificités qui lui
donne d'ailleurs une forme d'autorité
qui devrait lui donner en tout cas c'est
pas la chrétienté c'est la laïcité c'est
ça le principe les principes fondateurs
de notre république
maintenant si on remonte à plus que ça à
la royauté et tout ça on pourra dire oui
la france est catholique mais ça y est
monsieur briquet et ses amis ils doivent
comprendre que depuis deux cents ans
voire un peu plus
on est passé à l'époque moderne ou
maintenant la france elle est laïque
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut que nous
défendions alors en tout cas les
questions c'est vrai d'identité
d'immigration on en entend beaucoup
parler depuis quelques semaines depuis
quelques mois et pourtant c'est le
pouvoir d'achat qui est devenu le thème
dominant c'est le pouvoir d'achat qui
intéresse les français et cette campagne
avec des prix à la pompe on le disait
tout à l'heure qui bat de nouveaux
records le gouvernement a tenté de
donner quelques coups de pouce financier
aux consommateurs est-ce que c'est
suffisant maxence briquet
alors non seulement c'est pas suffisant
étant donné que ce cas par exemple
proposer mon macron de son ca prime
inflation qui au passage est ressorti à
toutes les sauces distribuez 100 euros
français et puis lorsqu'il s'agit de
l'essence ont dit que c'est pour les
sens lorsqu'il s'agit de l'électricité
on dit que c'est pour l'électricité
lorsqu'il s'agit des cours du quotidien
dit sur le court du quotidien la vérité
c'est que lorsqu'on prend cette prime
inflation et qu'on dit qu'elle sera
appliquée à l'essence par exemple les
clés français utilisons ces 100 euros là
pour leur plein le plein d'essence est
taxé à 60% donc 600 euros qui leur ont
été données très certainement avec de la
dette vu qu'on n'a pas la trésorerie en
france pour pour distribuer de l'argent
comme ça parce que ça fait 3 milliards 8
et l'argent ne tombe pas du ciel on
s'endette pour les français donc il
venait me croit quand même mis 600
milliards de dettes en plus sur la table
pendant son quinquennat et avec cette
date là on va donner de l'argent
français qu'il leur sera repris à 60%
avec des taxes donc c'est complètement
idiot enfin le le gouvernement propose
des mesures qui sont ici sont
relativement fumeuse terre en termes
d'applications que de résultats il est
évident qu'il n'y aura aucun résultat
probant à cela la vraie mesure qui
permettrait de dd les français pour leur
pouvoir d'achat c'est ce que propose l
examen c'est-à-dire que les entreprises
en bourse 50% des frais de carburant à
leurs employés qui font des leurs
trajets domicile travail en voiture ça
c'est une vraie mesure aujourd'hui c'est
fait pour les 100 sport en commun par
exemple et on souhaite nous que ça
s'applique à l'essence et plus largement
que de manière générale pour la
politique énergétique de la france on
essaye d'aller vers une sortie
utilisation moindre des énergies
fossiles donc avec l'électrification et
caetera et qu'on me sur le nucléaire qui
va être un atout majeur et non pas qu'on
me sur un beau mouvement qui dans tous
les cas graves autant d'énergies
fossiles tels medias pour fonctionner
jérôme lambert à la hausse des salaires
plus de justice sociale un thème que
devrait porter la gauche pourtant elle
reste aujourd'hui assez inaudibles
médiatiquement
écoutez c'est gentil de me donner la
parole ça me permet d'être un tout est
de rétablir un certain nombre de ces la
gauche et peut-être inaudibles parce que
personne aujourd'hui ne s'intéresse à ce
qu'elle vit mais ce que c'est un combat
effectivement de gauche le combat pour
le pouvoir d'achat le combat pour la
justice sociale
c'est toujours la gauche qu'il apportait
des grandes réformes et mably petit du
moyenne sous ce que vous voulez et des
réformes dans ce sens là vers plus de
justice c'est la gauche qui déportait
seul jamais été la droite je parle d'un
d'extrême droite qui elle quand elle a
gouverné dans notre pays ce sont des des
heures sombres mais le pouvoir d'achat
effectivement est un sujet majeur
c'est le premier sujet la premier sujet
de préoccupation des français et c'est
vrai que les comptes ne sont pas 100
euros de prix une inflation il n'y a pas
eu que ça il ya eu aussi le ch et
d'énergie les choses n'en fin quand on
additionne des petites mesurettes on
arrive quand même loin du complot loin
du compte et c'est vrai que
le groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale comme socialiste apparentés a
proposé que les entreprises
effectivement face un gros effort en
matière de prise en charge des frais de
transport comme ça se passe en région
parisienne ça c'est une réalité nous
l'avons demandé le sap a été écartée et
je voulais vous dire aussi il n'ya pas
que les français qui travaillent moi je
suis un député du monde rural il ya
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent dans le
monde mais aussi des personnes âgées il
ya aussi des jeunes qui font des études
qui se déplace et tous ces gens là
évidemment ne sont pas concernés ni par
le l'augmentation du barème des impôts
parce que la plupart du temps de des
frais d'épaulé impôts puisque la plupart
des gens c'est que ces personnes qui
vivent d'une manière très modestes ne
sont pas concernés par un impôt ils ne
payent pas d'impôts en tout cas pas
l'impôt direct pays payent beaucoup de
taxes c'est vrai donc la réduction des
taxes auraient un impact direct sur eux
mais la réduction de leur impôt n'a
aucun effet puisque elles ne payent pas
d'impôt sur le revenu donc les mesures
prises par le gouvernement sont très
très loin d'être à la hauteur des
attentes des français et des besoins des
français en axant son briquet encore un
mot sur le pouvoir d'achat même marine
le pen qui restait jusque là il ya peu
sur des thématiques sécuritaires de
l'immigration comme eric zemmour
aujourd'hui elle recentre sa campagne
sur le pouvoir d'achat
qu'en est-il à re conquête
nous pour le coup ce que marine le pen
propose si on l'a déjà vu c'est quand
même dû lui fantasmatique lorsque
lorsqu'elle nous sort sa mesure par
exemple sur la réduction de l'impôt sur
le revenu même l'exonération de l'impôt
sur le revenu pour les moins de 30 ans
c'est une mesure qui n'a qui n'a d'abord
aucun sens étant donné que la plupart
des moins de 30 ans ne paie pas d'impôt
sur le revenu en tout cas pour les plus
modestes et que pour ceux qui sont entre
le 10 mai les mieux lotis si j'ai envie
de dire ce sera en fait des étudiants
qui sortent de grandes écoles ou qui
sont surdiplômés qui en fait vous
bénéficier d'une exonération alors qu'il
n'en a pas besoin donc c'est typiquement
le genre de mesure qui sommes bien mais
qui n'a aucun effet la formation de
pouvoir d'achat une mesure forte
d'exercer la baisse de la csg pour les
salaires qui sont situés entre le smic
et 2000 euros qui va donner environ 1 12
200 euros par mois pour tous ces
salaires là donc là on est sur quelque
chose d'extrêmement concret on n'est pas
sur une exonération d'impôt sur le
revenu qui touchera quillanais mbappé ou
d'autres footballeurs qui gagnent des
millions on va être vraiment sûr les
gens qui ont le plus besoin d'être dans
notre pays les classes moyennes et les
personnes qui ont des travaux enfin qui
exercent un métier précaire si ces gens
là tu voudrais aujourd'hui en france
alors dans l'actualité également la
suite du scandale des ehpad 1 brigitte
bourguignon a annoncé des enquêtes
hier à l'assemblée le premier ministre
jean castex a répondu aux questions des
députés regarder
notre vigilance vous avez raison doit
s'appliquer à l'égard de tout le monde
ce qui suppose sûrement des plans de
contrôle plus nombreux et plus
performant je pense aussi comme l'ont
dit les professionnels du secteur
mesdames et messieurs les députés que
nous devons revoir les procédures
d'accréditation de ces établissements
alors notre vigilance doit s'appliquer à
l'égard de tout le monde ce qui suppose
sûrement des contrôles plus nombreux
plus performants nous devrons revoir les
procédures d'accréditation de ces
établissements jérôme lambert des
établissements privés qui reçoivent de
l'argent public que font les ars chargés
des contrôles
en fait c'est un vrai mais véritablement
problèmes d'accréditation
parce qu'au moment où ces établissements
comme tout autre établissement qui
reçoit du public mais ton mois reçoit
l'autorisation
vous pensez bien que le jour de
l'inauguration et quelques jours
auparavant tout est nickel tout est
parfait les dossiers sont bien notés
nice est un précédent la réalité
quotidienne que les choses se
compliquent voire devienne très très
problématique comme l'attestent
d'ailleurs différentes enquêtes qui sont
actuellement conduites et que nous
connaissions déjà parce que c'est en
tant que député je suis au courant
parfois de certaines situations et sur
lequel ge a tiré et il faut attirer
l'attention de la rs l ars qui
effectivement est en charge des
contrôles donc il s'agit bien de
contrôler mais comme vous voyez le
personnel affecté à ces contrôles c'est
proprement ridicule alors c'est vrai il
faut une prise de contrôle mais il faut
plus de moyens et il faut plus de moyens
aussi peut-être de moyens publics
d'ailleurs parce que alors je tends pas
des établissements privés les
établissements privés moi me pose une
difficulté majeure parce que c'est vrai
que qu'on gagne de l'argent tout ça fait
partie de l'air du temps c'est ça
toujours été nécessaire de tout seul
mais qu'on gagne de l'argent de certaine
façon est un problème quand on gagne de
l'argent sur la mort quand on gagne de
l'argent sur sur la maladie quand on
gagne de l'argent sur la misère des uns
des autres oui là c'est un problème et
ce qui se passe dans le secteur privé
mérite qu'on s'y attarde et que on
réforme grandement les
mécanismes la fois de financement et de
contrôle c'est zé palin ne doivent plus
reçoit recevoir de l'argent public selon
vous maxence briquet
selon moi le plus important et on est
d'accord avec monsieur lambert c'est le
fait que ces établissements ne sont pas
du tout à ces contrôles est grosso modo
toute la classe politique tous d'accord
sur ce constat là sauf qu'aujourd'hui
comme vous l'avez justement rappelé ce
sont les agences régionales de santé les
ars qui sont chargés de ce type de
contrôle et qu'elles ne font absolument
pas leur travail donc ce que proposait
l'examen c'est de supprimer ces ars qui
dans tous les cas ne servent à rien elle
nous montrait déjà pendant la crise
sanitaire l on était vraiment le
fer de lance de la lenteur
bureaucratique qui a fait qu'on avait
pas de masque on n'avait pas de tests
qui ont absolument pas associer les élus
terrain pour proposer des mesures plus
efficaces pour lutter contre la pandémie
à l'échelle locale beaucoup si toutes
ces raisons là font que nous souhaitons
qu'ils aient plus de contrôle c'est une
évidence et que les airs est dans tous
les cas ne l'ont jamais non jamais tenu
leur rôle de contrôleur des ehpad et que
nous souhaitons du coup de mouvaux
nouvelle mise en place de contrôles qui
serait institué à l'échelle nationale et
non plus par les agences régionales de
santé maxence briquet vous évoquiez tout
à l'heure marseille et les grands plans
voulu pour cette ville du chef de l'état
il se trouve qu'il ya une grève des
poubelles en ce moment c'est la
troisième en quatre mois il ya eu
pourtant un accord sur le temps de
travail à 35 heures mais la métropole
elle n'appliquera pas cet accord
correctement n'appliqueraient pas cet
accord correctement selon les syndicats
à quoi jouent les pouvoirs publics à qui
la faute jérôme lambert
j'aurai un peu de difficulté à
m'exprimer sur ce sujet bien sûr c'est
un sujet que vous abordez donc je suis
bien obligé d'essayer de vous répondre
quelque chose mais ce qui se passe à
marseille un petit peu loin de la
charente un petit peu loin de paris donc
comme en réalité je suis pas très au
fait je sais qu'il ya des difficultés
entre la la ville et la communauté
urbaine
l'organisme qui gère en tout cas le
service de ramassage je sais que la
ville souhaite je crois savoir en tout
cas que la ville souhaite récupérer une
partie de dés des moyens qui sont mis en
oeuvre par la communauté pour assurer
même le ramassage se faire assurer le
ramassage
c'est peut-être une meilleure solution
parce que ils se renvoient la patate
chaude manifestement c'est un faible
puisque comme on arrive toujours des
semaines et des semaines et des mois et
des années
parce que c'est le problème des
poubelles à marseille c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui et veillent donc wifi il
serait peut-être temps que les
communautés urbaines et la vie de marcel
ils s'entendent il ya des questions
politiques manifestement puisque l'un et
je dirais d'une couleur politique
l'autre et d'une autre couleur politique
c'est peut-être ça la difficulté mais
c'est pas normal parce qu'au bout du
compte ce sont des citoyens marseillais
qui en pâtissent l'économie marseillaise
aussi certainement parce que d'avoir des
poubelles partout dans la ville ça ne
doit pas facilité ni le commerce des
activités le maire socialiste de
marseille d'ailleurs très en colère qui
veut envoyer des sociétés privées
maxence briquet à un mot sur cette grève
à à marseille la troisième on l'appelle
en quatre mois ce n'est pas rien
vous savez je pense que ce qui se passe
à marseille à l'heure et forcément
accentuée par les problèmes de gestion
que connaît la ville et comme
connaissent aussi la métropole
nous on est sur des complexités qui sont
lors de la gestion des délégations de
service public du ramassage des déchets
qui sont accentuées encore une fois par
la situation économique de mars et la
situation politique mais qui ont lieu
dans énormément d'intercommunalité dans
énormément d'endroits vous avez des
divergences entre les compétences de la
mairie les la compétence de
l'intercommunalité
donc on va dire que ce qui se passe à
marseille et est assez révélateur des
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer les
différents échelons territoriales pour
s'organiser au niveau de la gestion des
différents services dont ils ont la
charge ça peut être le lot ça peut être
le ramassage scolaire ça peut être les
déchets ne peut pas grand chose à
ajouter si ce n'est que forcément
aujourd'hui à marseille le ramassage des
déchets est un problème mais que
l'insécurité la délinquance d'un
problème encore plus énorme il nous
reste très peu de temps mais peut-être
votre réaction écologie climat justement
près de 1400 chercheurs s'inquiètent de
l'absence de débat démocratique portant
sur le climat et la biodiversité dans la
campagne présidentielle et presse les
candidats de s'exprimer sur ces sujets
essentiels dans une tribune a paru hier
sur le site de france info pourquoi le
sujet peinent à s'imposer dans les
débats selon vous pour pour conclure
jérôme lambert
je pense quand même que c'est un sujet
qui fait assez largement consensus donc
on peut toujours débattre parce que il
est loin d'être réglée pour autant mais
chacun s'accorde ce qu'ils considéraient
qu'il ya un changement climatique dans
les principes différentes formes
évidemment mais ça passe surtout par le
réchauffement par des changements
beaucoup de deux régimes climatiques
mais c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
majeur celle-ci ici à 3 4 5 degrés de
plus à la fin de du siècle nos enfants
mes petits enfants connaîtront un monde
très différent du nôtre et qui posera
beaucoup de problèmes donc c'est un
sujet majeur la politique c'est celle du
quotidien c'est assurément du quotidien
il faut répondre à des attentes mais
celle-ci vision une vision de la société
vision du monde et des grands
responsables politiques mais moi je fais
partie de ceux qui militent depuis le
fort longtemps pour que une quinzaine
d'années environ mais premier rapport à
l'assemblée nationale sur le changement
climatique remonte à une quinzaine
d'années et maintenant et je crois que
il faut agir plus fort je dis pas qu'on
fait rien mais on fait largement passé
maintenant la france n'est pas toute
seule dans le monde satu siens agir plus
fort on vous a entendu il vous reste
quelques secondes maxence brickell le
mot de la fin sur le climat justement
non je pense que le climat est également
un sujet prioritaire est préoccupant
pour les français on en veut pour preuve
de toutes les politiques soudainement
extrêmement ambitieuse en matière de
nucléaire par exemple qui est venu
macron a sorti de son chapeau ou valérie
pécresse alors que même un cran du pô le
coup a passé tout son quinquennat à
démolir ce que notre savoir faire en
matière de nucléaire eric zemmour lui
prend à bras le corps ce sujet du
changement climatique et de la
souveraineté énergétique du pays qui
sont le sujet qui vont de pair avec le
nucléaire les moines construire une 14
acteurs européens d'ici 2050 pour
assurer à la fois l'augmentation des
besoins d'électricité qui vont arriver
avec l'augmentation de population par
exemple mais aussi avec
l'électrification du chauffage des
bâtiments avec peut-être
l'électrification de la voiture et des
transports dont notamment un enjeu plus
important si on ne veut pas avoir de
black-out en france et de l'autre par
exemple les règlements souhaite qu'on
revienne sur cette loi absurde qui
souhaite réduire de 50% la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix électrique qui
encore une fois je rappelle le nucléaire
a toute souveraineté extrêmement
important et qui n'aimait que six
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure produit
là où le charbon à 400 ou 500 qui sont
centrales à charbon d'ailleurs qui ont
été rallumés ou en tout cas renforcé par
le gouvernement parce qu'il n'ya plus
fessenheim pour alimenter notre notre
réseau électrique donc je puis vous
assurer que le sujet est très
préoccupant et qu'il existe on le
prendra le corps on arrive au terme du
temps qui nous est imparti le nucléaire
effectivement un débat que l'on pourra
traiter sur cette hantise merci à tous
les deux merci avoue jérôme lambert
merci à vous de maxent ce briquet
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
sur arte france